こちられ配置だけど皆さん2018年問も終わりあの毎年ちゃってるんですけども
肇社長のスマホの中の動画を全部見て以降のコーナー2018年あの自慢じゃないん
ですけどもスマホの中変な動画やバイトが色々入っておりますこうやっぱ人前にさらす
と炎上するようなこともゆちなが楽しめるみたいなところ
結構派過激なことは深く的スマホの中で行ってしまいます肇社長ですあの程島の我
ながら比較的塩蔵したことが大変少なかった大人スイート4でしたありがとうござい
ます遠藤したいわけじゃないんですけども
ことちょっと大人しすぎたんで来年はもうちょっと
[音楽]
炎上しない程度に盛り上がればいいなと思っています皆さんよろしくお願いしますそう
いう気でスマホの中身ていきましょう
上野幌小たくない人ダメの
[音楽]
ゆくりびんデビューグゥーっ
あってからを奏月歌的な雪山言ったのを覚えてますね
rar
おまんちゃんは寝正月実家帰れなくてこんなことをするんだよ
なぜません
新たな家ですね
なってその棒を見ました
[音楽]
でたなぁこれなんかで東京のドーン機に対応
ん
なんだ嘘はっきりしたな
嘘発見器ですタブー
[音楽]
おっぱいは嫌いですかいいえ
あっ大家さんちのいいんですね尻尾めちゃめちゃ喜んでっぽいつけたの僕なんかいいね
にめちゃ吠えられるんですよ
ちくそー
[音楽]
[拍手]
はあああ
住んでバック0
下ろそうとサラブツ切れて作るこれ第19が大道路通して交渉としてますね
ガラ悪いやかおかおの顔の柄が悪いもう
リアルゴールドたくさん持ってあげたんですけどまたなっちが遊戯王カードやっている
ところですかね
すごい頑張って考えてますねまあ全身5敗
花好きなぬいぐるみがあったんで取ろうと思って頑張ってるとます
ん味は誰だったらの歯茎スターダメ
今年でめっちゃゲーセンに行ってる気がするよな
難しいこれあの中に入ろうと思った入れて動きだったようですね
結構怖いんですけど生揚げしていってねちょっときつかったんだよねもう版の
封印の表は x 線によって頑張ってましたね
[音楽]
これはちょっと動画件しようか迷ったわけでバブないから辞めたんですけどあの車の上
に1乗って雲仙できるかっていう実験やってました
意外と出来ないですけどやっぱ部ないんで童顔だしな楽です
今しちゃいましたいやこれめっちゃ3つ難しくて9安打4なぁ
多分これ3000ぐらい使ってようやく撮れ later はず
トレでもで嬉しくないんですよね
本地たくさん使い3位タイだった
なません使いましたと思う
[音楽]
家の方のお祭りに行って願ったりビンゴ大会に景品を渡すっていうのがありました今年
はもうちょっとああもう帰れなかったんですけれどもねゆっくりちゃまにも痛いところ
がありますね
バッハ
あっは
ああああああ
これならいざかやの外で寝てるなかったも酔って潰れて濡れた人が入ったんですけど
なんかとありで出てみようかなと思って一緒に寝たやつですね懐かしいこれ
プテラノドン
届いた時なんですけどもでかすぎてトラックの運ちゃんとあの皆で一緒に運んだって
いう
マジでかかったトラックもうめっちゃ体感できた今年なんかゲームしかしてないです
けど運動も素晴らしい
んだと思って山レポにめっちゃハマってましたね結構もう一番難しいレベルとかも割と
できるようにありますが台風な日もパズドラでランク上げている時ですね
どんなときも私はパズドラ頑張りましたねな肉筆のこれ
内日角がう
出しか電話するときになかっんそういう声を聞かせてあげます
いやーちょっと見せられないものが多すぎますね基本で見たが凍ってるんでうーん
ちょっとお見せできないのが残念で道具消されてしまうとちょっと嫌なんで頭日常的な
ものは畑てこうどんどん動画で行っちゃってるんでちょっとスマホの動画が溜まり
にくくなったのがあるかなと思いますみなさん
スマホにはどんな動画が入っているのでしょうか来年も節度をも背負いの取れればいい
なって思ってるんで
お刺身じゃん
[音楽]